Although this may make you want to smack your
head against the wall repeatedly, the fact
of the matter is; everything is maths.
From your phone to your house, the tiny particles
that everything is made of and the giant,
swirling galaxies that dot the infinite universe;
all of that is based on numbers.
But before you start throwing tomatoes at
the screen, as you are part of the large majority
of people who hates numbers and their evil
behavior, don’t worry, no formulas or tests
today.
It’s strange though, isn’t it, this anger
towards something that is so vital to our
lives, and that mathematicians are seen as
strange wizards with their nerdy number magic.
So today, we look at magic numbers that rule
your life, and possibly death.
Let’s start with a nice safe one; ten.
We all like ten, it’s the girl next door
of mathematics; you get ten, you know ten,
ten is your friend.
But why is this?
Why are we so comfortable around those lovely
rounded tens, twenties and hundreds but it
all gets so murky when you veer away from
them?
Well the simple answer is; habit.
The only reason we work in tens is because
we have ten fingers and it just became common
practice to do it like that.
These are called “bases”.
A base is just how you decide to group your
numbers.
We work in base ten so you have the numbers
zero to nine, if you add one more to nine
then you complete a group of ten, and so you
move onto the next group.
So if we worked in base four, you’d have
the numbers zero to three and when you add
one more then you complete a group of four.
We feel like 10 is logical but an alien society
is just as likely to work in some other base.
It wouldn’t be a problem though, we could
easily “translate” it into friendly looking
tens.
Many cultures have used other bases, either
partially or completely.
French for example, mixes in base 20 with
base 10.
“Quatre vingt dix neuf” is 99 but translates
as “four twenties and nineteen”.
The Oksapmin people of New Guinea have a base-27
counting system, with each number being named
after a separate body part, which is how they
keep track.
So, I’ll have ear apples, elbow carrots
and belly button slices of bacon please.
Probably the most important number of all
time is zero.
It seems like such an obvious thing to us
but it was missing from many early counting
systems.
The Sumerians were the first people to develop
a counting system but it was all about keeping
stock of cattle and horses so you didn’t
need a number for something that you didn’t
have.
It was Brahmagupta, an Indian mathematician
from the 7th century who formalized zero by
representing it as a dot under a number.
He also wrote rules about its use.
It reached the west through trade from Arabia,
with the Arabian mathematicians making great
advances in many areas of mathematics and
Mohammed ibn-Musa al-Khowarizmi creating equations
which resulted in zero, or algebra, as it
is now known.
The word zero itself is from Arabic, along
with algebra, algorithm and average.
Without zero, we never would have been able
to create binary code, which gave us computers.
So life would be very different today; I would
probably be shouting all these facts in some
town square somewhere and then maybe burnt
as a witch.
Can you tell me what these numbers have in
common?
2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13, 17, 19?
That’s right, they are prime numbers.
A prime is a number that only divides by one
and by itself, we don’t include 1 as a prime.
Now, for non-mathematical people, you might
think?
Who cares?
Why does everyone talk about primes like they
are so important?
The thing is, prime numbers are like elements
in chemistry; they are the building blocks
that everything is made of.
2,3,5… these are just like Hydrogen, Helium,
Lithium and so on.
Every non-prime, or composite number as they
are called, can be made by multiplying two
prime numbers together.
Fifteen, for example is 3 x 5.
Ninety-Four is 2 x 47.
What’s more, all even numbers are the sum
of two prime numbers.
Ninety Four is 89 + 5
The multiplication of primes may just sound
like a dull quirk of mathematics but it has
a very real benefit for us internet users;
security.
Multiplying two primes together might be easy
but working backwards is very very difficult.
If I give you a number and tell you to work
out what primes it’s made up of, you basically
have to try out all the combinations until
you find the correct one; there is no formula.
If it’s a small number, that’s not so
bad but when you get up into something that’s
hundreds or thousands of digits long, yeah…
good luck with that.
So internet security, which is active when
you see HTTPS at the beginning of a web address,
uses this quirk of mathematics to encode your
sensitive data; you need the correct key in
order to solve this prime multiplication problem
each time.
Finding new prime numbers can be a rewarding
business since there are a range of prizes
on offer, with hundreds of thousands of dollars
being offered for ones over 100 million digits
long.
The current record holder for the world’s
largest prime number was only just discovered
in January 2016 and the number itself is over
22 million digits long.
Although we picked 10 because of what our
hands look like, there are some numbers that
are important throughout the universe, such
as 3.14… or Pi.
Carl Sagan, the famous astrophysicist, wrote
a novel Contact, which became a big movie.
When humans find the number Pi in a radio
signal from the stars, we know it’s a sign
of intelligent life because this number must
be universal to everyone, regardless of how
many fingers the alien species has.
Pi is actually quite a simple concept.
If you take a circle and divide its circumference
by its diameter, then you always get the same
answer because this is just the ratio that
makes a circle.
It’s everywhere; car tyres, coke cans, actual
pies and Karl Pilkington’s impressively
round face.
And it’s been invaluable for all of science,
and has led engineering advances for thousands
of years.
There are other constant numbers like e, which
is 2.718, that is used for many things but
famously on working out interest in banking.
I’m sure we all have a lot of interest in
banking.
But one constant that is much more exciting
is Phi; the golden ratio.
The number is about 1.618 and it’s all about
proportions.
Take a rectangle and add the short side to
the long side.
If the rectangle is in this perfect golden
ratio then the long side will be 1.618 times
longer than the short side.
The reason we’re interested in it is that
is seems to appear in nature all the time,
especially when you apply it to spirals; the
seeds of a sunflower, the swirl of a galaxy,
pinecones, hurricanes.
You can see examples of the golden ratio in
ancient buildings and a huge number of paintings.
It’s often been suggested that it is the
number of pure beauty and that a face with
features matched in the golden ratio is going
to be the most universally popular, so make
sure you have a ruler out ready, next time
you’re on tinder.
Even if you are one of the many people who
would rather lick a toilet bowl than work
out a percentage, it’s good to know that
maths is out there, doing its job, even without
your help and appreciation, you ungrateful
little monkey.
And of course, even though it’s not on this
list, all of us know which number is really
the secret answer to the universe, don’t
we?
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more … um…
add the three… divide by seven… that’s
it, subscribe for more Thoughty2.